Here are my blood results taken yesterday, not what I wanted to see.
Any suggestions from here? One question does detox using supplements, food
rife, I am throw away of Castro packs, et cetera, increase the numbers six
months all through the keynote. So I did write down this person's blood work,
what was elevated the AST, the alkaline phosphatase in the CBA. But I did
notice that we didn't have any data on past numbers for this person. So I can't
make a comparison. So I'm assuming that this person is saying that these
words elevated prior to this test, or they're at a higher level than they
were six months ago. But let's talk about that. Elevated AST indicates liver
issues, but it's not specific. So it's not a specific test like, oh, you have
fatty liver disease. It just elevates elevated AST is liver enzyme, and that will
be elevated if you have liver congestion. Could it be the testuses in liver?
Well, it can be elevated with the testuses in liver, but a lot of people have
AST, elevations in liver testuses in liver, they don't even have cancer. Has
nothing to do with cancer. In its raw form, it could be completely independent.
CEA is a tumor marker. So if CEA is elevated from prior, then that's a
concern because that's an elevated tumor marker. So if your tumor goes up, again,
you don't take one test by itself. You measure it with other signs and symptoms
and other objective findings. So if your seat, let's say you did a CT scan
of the tumor shrunk, but the CEA went up in a PET scan, and there's no new signs
of any metastasis, but the CEA went up. Well, then you might just ignore that
CEA test in a sense. You put it in the back pocket and you might look at
other objective tests. I don't have baseline on where the CEA was, and if you
don't have a baseline of the CEA, and it's elevated above normal, you have no idea
what it was before. Maybe it was much higher. So you compare the data of a test to
the previous test. Well, it was my first one. Okay, well, then it just you already know
you have cancer. So it's very common to have an elevated tumor marker like CEA,
which was fairly broad tumor marker. If you have cancer, so if you don't have any
to compare it to, it's, you know, to be a point that we got to baseline. So
alkaline phosphatases are totally different animals. So alkaline phosphatases
are another liver enzyme, but it's not, so it can be elevated if there's, if
there's congestion in the liver, if there's toxicity in the liver, if, you
know, if there's metastasis in the liver, but a common reason why alkaline phosphatase
is elevated with people that have a previous cancer diagnosis is metastasis to
bone. So your oncologist should be looking for that. If you see alkaline phosphatase
be elevated with a patient that has a diagnosis of cancer, we should be looking at
bone. So how do you look at bone? Your bone scan, your pen scan, you do a CT scan if the
person has, CT scans are regional. So the issue with that is, you just, you know,
a whole body regional CT scans. So then you, you limit your CT scan if the person
had, let's say, they had screaming low back pain, you do a CT scan, it's better
scanned to visualize the bone in MRI. So you do a CT scan of the lumbar spider, the
lumbar back or the lumbar abdominal area. And you'd make sure that there isn't any
body metastasis because if there is a lytic metastasis, meaning that bone is being
eroded away, which is the most common type of body metastasis for any type of cancer is
an elytic metastasis, not a plastic metastasis, which is laid out of bone. So you got a
body erosion. It gives off and elevates your alkaline phosphatase. So not to concern you,
which you've got to be a realist, you've got to go, okay, but I'll elevate it out
the phosphatase, your, your oncologist shouldn't be going, we need to be located making sure
that there's no body metastasis. And then if there is, if you do find body metastasis and
then you're working at treated it, then you will, and if you're successful at it, you will
see, um, you will see that I'll get phosphatase, but I don't actually had a console with somebody
the other day that that was exactly the case. His alkaline phosphatase dropped back down